[Music]
over the last few years the worldwide
Wellness industry has exploded in
popularity and profitability that it's
estimated to be worth around 4.2
trillion dollars a year but if you
thought it was all about Gwyneth
Paltrow's intimately scented candles or
something kale smoothies while adopting
the downward dog and my next guest is
here to put you right Wim Hof is the
Dutch lifestyle Guru whose radical
extreme cold therapy method has made him
a Sunday Times bestselling author and
motivational speaker to Millions more
importantly in a world of snowflakes is
promised to freeze a fear by putting ice
in our veins it surely needed more than
ever I'm thrilled to say the Iceman
joins me now well welcome to Piers
Morgan uncensored Wim thank you very
much indeed for joining me
thank you pierce for having me on your
conversation thank you well I'm kind of
fascinated by you because I it was a few
quotes you came out with you said we are
as a society have become snowflakes
doctors prescribe too many pills
treating symptoms like anxiety and
depression but not the cause connection
with nature is profound cold water is
the remedy exercise connection with the
natural world is Paramount redicted to
phones iPads laptops and machines
despite dopamine but it's futile and
makes us miserable Tech has made us weak
and I when I read that I was like
Hallelujah that somebody with a big
following with influence is saying what
is clearly ever more obvious
yes and it is so we have uh abstracted
through our technology and I welcome
technology but I welcome biological
technology of the human body even more
how to maintain and activate and create
and guarantee our own happiness strength
and health we lost that connection with
us so I came up with a way to tap into
the deeper physiology and endorse it by
scientific uh uh scrutiny by comparative
studies so there is no speculation about
it we got they injected us a group I
trained into this method in four days
and they were able to withstand a
endotoxin that is a E coli bacteria
injected into the veins and they were
able to bring down these symptoms
whereas sixteen thousand others could
not and now suddenly 12 people trained
by me in four days were able to bring
down to suppress the inflammation caused
by a bacteria and that is revolutionary
it shows that we lost the connection
with our deeper systems inside which is
the immune system the endocrine system
the cardiovascular system and we have no
control over that anymore and now I have
shown by going into nature then going
through science
showing it in groups that we are able to
retrieve a deep connection with our
systems and at command are able to
exercise power over that What Makes Us
sick depressed and lack of energy you
know it's very it's fascinating and I've
got I've got to say quite an increasing
number of friends who go and do this
Wild Water Swimming you know freezing
cold and jump in and they swear by it
they they think it's been really good
for their mental health it's been good
for their physical health
um so I I definitely sense a lot of
people are trying forms of this
um what's interesting to me uh is how
you really got into this and the sort of
pivotal moment in your life came through
utter tragedy where your first wife uh
took her own life she was suffering from
schizophrenia uh took her own life and
you were left with your four children
and it inspired you to really go down
this road of ice cold as a form of
therapy for you how important do you
think that that was for you in getting
over that appalling tragedy
back then there was no other remedy in
my life I had little money for kids
alone and a wife she was the love of my
life so you are heartbroken emotionally
you are in agony it goes around around I
had no control over that but I remember
to go into the cold at the cold it makes
you stop thinking
it just breaks the loop of the emotional
Agony and that directly gave me a relief
just a little time without being into
that Loop was able to bring about this
healing from the inside so of course I
went on doing this all the time since 95
and I did it very consciously because I
had to bring up four kids alone with
little money the cold I tell you pierced
the cold and the breathing techniques
they gave me all the bloody energy to
make a warm nest for my children amazing
and make me able to process all the
emotional Agony and now I say what back
then the oldest psychiatrists did not
know I am working right now with the
best psychiatrists of the world to show
that we we are so much more capable to
tap into our emotional Agony and learn
to process trauma we got him we got him
and I want to bring it and therefore I
thank you for me bring it through your
show to so many people well I think
honestly I think it's a really I think
it's really interesting and never mind
nothing else you've broken 21 Guinness
world records including I'm going to
read some of these out running a half
marathon above the Arctic Circle
barefoot in shorts swimming underneath
ice for 66 meters hanging on one finger
at an altitude of 2 000 meters climbing
the highest mountains in the world while
wearing again only shorts and standing
on a container while covered with ice
cubes for more than 112 minutes now
apart from the fact that you're clearly
well you're different to the rest of
this is how I put it politely which of
those was the hardest
the hardest is where it was most
impressive every time I do a world
record I am ready
to take on fully hundred percent of my
body and mind I know how to do that I
learned how to climb without gear uh
steep walls I learned to trust myself
breath hold and swim 60 70 80 meters
under the eyes Just Breath hold and in
short things like that you cannot do if
you don't do do it with a full
confidence and trust and control within
so my twin brother my identical twin
brother is absolutely not able to do
what I do do his body is the same as me
genetically but I am very able to do it
so I saw if you train your body you are
able to do what in science
physiologically okay is thought
impossible well I've got to jump in
because I wanted to end by actually
enacting your work we found a member of
the talk TV team Lauren who is a massive
fan of yours and we thought of you such
a big fan we'd strip him down and Chuck
him in to an ice bucket at the top of
our building so Lauren has a tribute to
Wim Hof and thank you win very much and
D for coming on Facebook and uncensored
we have a very uncensored member of
talktv's Team about to ice himself
hopefully not to death take it away
Laura
cheers Bears ready
good luck Lauren
breathe deep
in control
you
lovely wait how long do we leave him
there
two minutes until
mascularly he is totally at ease all
right leaving the job is done all right
leave him five minutes until total
paralysis sets in he's he's not had the
best of years here so it's the only
punishment he'll understand I think it
will not happen uh Lauren Drinkers and
you've had a very good year uh well
thank you very much indeed for joining
me I appreciate it
love it thank you good luck stay cold